Greg said I've had some studies on how
as men get older their sperm mutates and
it leads to children being born with
disabilities is a good rule to have kids
before 40. I've not heard that from what
I understand it's the mother that uh
leads to high-risk pregnancies as she
gets older I mean I've seen lots of guys
50 60 even I think I know a guy 71 that
had a very healthy kid as well I mean he
won't be around long to see that kid
Crow up but
um yeah from what I understand it's it's
her ability to carry the child I mean as
she gets older the pregnancy starts to
get called a high risk pregnancy so it's
not a good idea to do that with an older
chick
yeah who cares Before 40 thing is more
so like how old do you want to be when
you're chasing them around how old do
you want to be you know when the energy
levels you're going to have and you're
older uh and that sort of thing so
but I haven't yeah I haven't heard
anything like that either
did you guys have plans to have kids
Jaren and Chris
I'd like to
um you know still relatively young but I
think the window would be between 35 and
40. uh but yeah I definitely would like
to
yeah I'm kind of I'm kind of there too
I've been on the fence but looking back
when I was a kid I always really wanted
them um I was the oldest in a family of
uh four uh like myself my siblings and I
pretty much raised my younger siblings
so I know I'm good at it like they're
all they're all Champions I'm super
proud of them like we were really close
they all they all admire me respect me
so I'm like all right well if I if I
could raise kids when I was like eight
you know I was putting that unfortunate
position I'd like to do it now at the
World experience I have but really it
comes down to finding a correct partner
so I'm not saying like I'm gung-ho like
really like that's what I'm focused on
trying to do it but I'm keeping my eyes
open and I'm vetting these chicks a lot
more so like if someone potentially
Falls in that camp ideally um if I were
to do it I'd like to do it you know
before 40 early 40s at the latest uh due
to the the energy question but it's
really hard since I've changed my
standards in my head of what I'm going
to accept in terms of like girls I hang
out with one you get an influx of Desire
because literally you just you're just
turning them down all day long it's like
yeah you're you and I aren't compatible
you're not good for me I don't see you
as mother material women don't like
being told that we've discussed this in
the group many times but um yeah they
they really they really put on the ACT
once once you you know I'm not mean
about I'm just like hey you and I have
different different philosophies
different ways we view life and uh
different things we want and the
different ways we go about it you know
we're just not compatible for anything
long-term but hey in the meantime you
can have fun hook up and hang out and
all that good stuff but uh so yeah for
me it's really a question of if the
right person comes along I'm not going
to announce I'm looking for them but
I'll keep my eyes open and if if someone
comes along then yeah ideally I'd like
to have kids too would you guys move to
a part of the world where it's
friendlier to fathers like I'm not sure
what the deal is with Mexico moths in
the states I mean
um Florida is actually a good state for
it Tennessee is a good state for I think
Tennessee's probably ranked the highest
as far as friendliness to fathers
Kentucky but some of those yeah yeah
you're right yeah because it's like
default shared custody like you
basically have to prove the other
parents of degenerate you know to have a
custodial order for the kids all the
time but is that something that you
would consider too Jaren like what's it
like in Mexico have you looked at the
rules or
yeah I know it's changing um I I hear a
lot of guys complaining but I know that
it still kind of favors doing what's
best for kids so I've met a lot of girls
too where they have like no custody of
the kids and it's just a matter of they
were young and hot married an older rich
guy the divorce happened usually like we
know why you know the girl cheats or
something or a lot of times it's the uh
the girl gets older she spits out the
kids the the guys having affairs with
other girls because like it's kind of
part of the culture like you just have
side chicks if you're a solid dude it's
known that you have multiple chicks here
um and a lot of times the girls don't
like that so they leave or they cheat or
whatever it's all about like the social
status thing so the guy throws her out
he's got some money and he gets full
custody so that is possible here I've
heard of guys getting screwed over that
the courts are changing but it's usually
guys that you'd expect to allow those
things to happen so the alpha guys don't
really have that problem as far as from
what I've seen um so for me the question
would be do I want to raise a family in
Mexico and if so where in Mexico I like
Mexico City it's a little more liberal
though it's a bigger city so I'd
probably go to Guadalajara or even go up
to like north northern Baja California
some close to the U.S from San Diego I'm
just a direct flight away from my
hometown two hours away so I'm not I'd
do something like that again I haven't
given it too much thought but the idea
has gone through my head especially I
live in a nice neighborhood there's a
all girls school literally right down
beneath me here and it's a really good
high quality school like international
school because you know when I'm walking
down the street they'll talk to you and
stuff in perfect English and very well
educated so I've noticed and I've dated
girls that have gone to the
international schools in other countries
and they're usually waiting did you
spoke about the neighborhood before you
got that apartment there like knowing
that there's an all-girls like college
there sort of thing I didn't realize it
was in all girls college until I had
moved in I knew I knew it was some sort
of school but I figured it was like a
mixed-use public school but no it's a
private school um there's a lot just
like uh like what are the main courses
that they it's well it's a K-12
so it's a it's a it's a private Jewish
school there's a lot there's a large
Jewish population where I live so I mean
you're dealing like sorry so it's a k
through 12 all girls equivalent to K-12
yeah their their version of public
education so what's like the age of a
grade 12 girl there
same as the US uh I think they do the
1899 yeah 18 17 18. you're going super
young then eh oh I'm not going after him
I'm just walking around doing my stuff
but I'll talk to you no I'm not I'm not
going after him okay all right 50 I saw
you unmute yourself there do you have
some yeah I just wanted to know what the
Mexican phrase for side chick was from
Jaron that's all
right
I'd probably just say like a month like
like lover yeah Rich going back to what
you know your the initial question about
the guy joining the community
so um my daughter whacked her toe a few
weeks ago and my ex was like she's got
to go to the orthopedic she's got to go
to the orthopedic she's with you you
gotta take her blah blah blah so I call
up a guy who's a member of the community
who's a top orthopedic surgeon and he's
worked on sports stars and he spends
half an hour on the phone with me and
he's asking me what's this what's that
you know what are symptoms what's this
and you know he you know he told me what
to look for and I explained it to him
and he said nothing's broken there he
said that's fine don't bother him he
said and again that's an untapped
resource or it's a tapped resource and
the community becomes what you use it
for yeah I I always tend to defer to
fixers in the community before anybody
outside just because I know like and
trust them better plus they're unplugged
right like we're not dealing with
plugged in betas that could potentially
put you at risk by dispensing
irrelevant or dangerous advice you know
for being honest
um hey 50 I'm asking this question since
we were talking about kids is there any
you know because you're you're a
seasoned man kind of like you know close
to my uh part of life and I'm just
wondering you know is there anything you
would do differently for any advice that
you would give guys when it comes to you
know considering kids or raising kids or
picking mother suck
uh I would advise guys not to not to
panic you know not to not to not to take
the blue pill thing of you have to have
kids now like when I looked about how I
was plugged in it's like you you get
pressure from family Society everything
you're a party and you're having a good
time you're focused on a career you need
to find a good girl and settled down
that that can be the death sentence for
some people because they'll they'll
lower every barrier they have and they
will settle for some some girls with
baby rabies who uh who's at you know
31-32 yeah and I'll just say resist the
pressure and focus on yourself focus on
your career because you know we can say
our children into well into our 50s
there's a video that I just published
today on the entrepreneurs and cars
Channel like literally half an hour
before we started this cast uh title is
she wants a baby but not him
um you should go watch that because it's
relevant to exactly what we're talking
about what 50 just said essentially is a
lot of guys
um you know the tldr version of that
video is she's 38 he's he's 38 she
doesn't love him but wants to have
babies and he is her only and last
chance and you'd be surprised how many
guys get into long-term relationships
marriages cohabitation type Styles and
have kids with women that aren't
enthusiastic about them that end very
very badly I've seen the movie dozens
and dozens of times
um and that's a you know figure of
speech there's no movie out there like
that but what I'm saying is I've talked
to so many guys that have gone through
that so many times it's like it always
ends the same way you know when she has
the kids and then she realizes that
she's still not in love with him and
nothing has changed in fact maybe she's
become more distant that's when she's
like well I think I'm going to get
divorced now and go find my chat and
I've got my kids so that's out of the
way and she leaves him and takes half of
his [ __ ] and he rarely if ever sees a
kid so it's like something you have to
be very very aware of right I don't
think kids oh go ahead no it'll be sure
I don't think men realize how they will
adjust their standards when they have
baby rabies what they will put up what
they will do absolutely everything to
everything they will become a different
person
another Point too we've been talking
about in the community lately how the
term of like a female loser so I think a
lot of times the pressure that women get
is because around them like their own
moms their own sisters their own
girlfriends especially you know there
are a lot of times they're followers so
they see all the all of the their female
sphere of influence going down this road
like oh my God what about me and and
they feel as though they're less than if
they don't do it doesn't necessarily
mean they want them although you know
there is that biological clock that's
ticking but you have to be really
careful guys too especially when you're
you're in your later 30s or even dating
Marion trying to have kids with chicks
over 30s one not only the health thing
like her you know the eggs are getting
older there are higher likelihood of
having issues with that but also too A
lot of times the kid's not going to be
yours and I know what's the study it's
like one-third of babies born in the U.S
or not from the dad that they think they
are and I know there's guys there's guys
in the community that like do the bull
thing like uh like a big big black in
Canada and there's been girls I've dated
before where like everything's going
really well um you know we're not using
birth and all of a sudden she ghosts me
months later I see a post like oh I'm
pregnant I'm just like you can do the
math in your head in fact there's a
couple where I'm like I'm pretty sure
like that time's up just about right and
then there's girls that I dated in
college same kind of thing all of a
sudden they ghost me and I'm like oh
you're married the whole the whole
[ __ ] time what the hell and then you
see the post on Facebook you're like oh
yeah uh four of your kids like you have
four kids three of them look like
they're white trash one of them clearly
looks like me so like I think you Gotta
Be You gotta be really careful and it's
it's not me boasting it's very common
it's it's difficult to assess the uh
real numbers when it comes to paternity
fraud I talked about it in my book in at
least a couple of the chapters
um and I spent some time in it
definitely in one of the chapters for
sure but
um it's it's nearly impossible to get
accurate data because paternity fraud is
deceptive and if you think you're gonna
get
um you know real volunteer information
from women you know deceiving fathers
into becoming fathers and you're sadly
mistaken the now there was an
interesting study that I came across
that was very difficult to find actually
was suppressed I found it in a link to
um a forum somewhere didn't even show up
on a Google search but it was an old
Toronto Star article where there was a
school somewhere in the UK
um I think from your neck of the woods
50 where they had asked the kids
um to do a family tree and without
screwing up the details because I don't
recall them that specific because it was
two two and a half years ago that I
wrote this but essentially they found
out after all the kids came back and
they started to collect the data that
about a third of the kids in the
classroom
um found out that that their fathers
weren't their father so they weren't
allowed to do this exercise anymore
because it was too harmful to the
children
but I think it's safe to estimate
somewhere somewhere in the low end
around 10 percent and probably maybe on
the higher end around 20 percent of kids
that are born to to men today
um uh they are not they're not the
fathers you know she's deceived him into
believing that he is and he takes
ownership for it one of the interesting
things that I found as well is that
um and I didn't put this in the book is
that children when they're born look
identical to their fathers to the to
their biological father so I have a
picture I didn't you know do this
intentionally but this was like you know
quite a while ago but when my daughter
was born there's a picture in the
hospital because her eyes are all closed
and you know they don't have any hair on
their head sort of thing so they kind of
look like you you know when you're
balding or you know you shave your head
so I took a picture of her face you know
beside my face and the structure of the
eyebrows the nose everything looks
identical and it was shocking
um but you know as they get older and
they start to develop and they go
through you know like all the growth
spurts they start to look obviously you
know more more like a female and their
mother you know sort of thing but um
yeah it's like a safety mechanism I
think nature puts in place
um because they want to reduce the rates
of infanticide right because
um in nature generally speaking I mean
if you look at a lot of um Wildlife like
I know Lions do this you know when they
take over Pride like even hippos do this
zebras do this you know when they take
over the alpha role if there's any
um newborns calves you know Cubs or
whatever they actually kill them you
know because it puts the the females
into estrus so that they you know go
back in ovulation cycles and then they
can start you know having their own kids
you know their own offspring with those
animals so
um it's not that uncommon actually yeah
it's really funny right how this whole
idea of The Stepfather Dynamic these
guys are always praised as Heroes and as
like Knights and shining armor but on
the other side of that coin they're also
the most dangerous person when it comes
to bringing that into your family
especially if you have young daughters
so oh stepfathers are so great it's like
okay but how come how about the ones
that say okay these aren't my kids I
don't give a [ __ ] about these kids all
the case and those get buried and those
don't get talked about because again
it's
um we're out there to save the women
we're out there to save the single
mothers that sort of stuff so that's
always really interesting that people
will choose not to bring that up and the
fact that these guys in a lot of
situations I mean they are the most
dangerous predator when it comes to
um children is is our fathers and
usually it's fathers because again you
don't you don't see a lot of single
fathers running around out there it's
mostly single mothers
um so all praise to this to the step
dads but they're the same ones that's oh
yeah a dad that stepped up and then five
years later he's drowned two of the kids
or whatever it is it's [ __ ] up it's
also the number one search for a term I
think on the uh adult video sites which
you should be telling
which is what uh
no stepdad stepdaughter oh yeah yeah
yeah that's the sort of
um genre that Sterling does from from
what I recall that's what he kind of
specials and is the step dad sort of
um role yeah but he used to sell ads on
those platforms he's like bro it's step
daughter step daughter all your stepdad
stepdaughter all day long yeah yeah it's
yeah it's bizarre but it's like you know
it's one of the problems with society
today is like you know men are now
praised for being the father that
stepped up you know so to speak there's
even t-shirts you know made about
stepdads you know stepping up and you
see these like celebration videos where
it's like
um you know there's official adoption
paper and he's sitting at the table he's
like fat and destroyed sort of thing and
some like 17 year old like handsome sort
of thing and she's like yes I've been
adopted by you and he's like oh yeah
I've adopted DNA that's not mine you
know sort of thing like let's celebrate
but yeah so for the woman she wins
I think what's a huge one really
interesting conversation station to go
back really quick about you know the
pool of women from mother stock and
things like that you know there's there
seems to be two schools of thought where
some guys will talk about look like you
can do whatever you want if your value
is high enough and if you're not finding
women that are so so for me specifically
people want to always kind of rag on me
by when I say yeah I'm probably not
going to get married most likely but I'd
still like to have kids well good luck
trying to find a woman that'll have your
kids and not marry you and say well
first of all kids are born out of
wedlock literally every day so that's
dumb but two
yeah I'm not discounting the fact that
the pool may be smaller of women that
are willing to do that so the two
options are it's like okay cool well
then just build your value higher where
a woman will be essentially not making a
rule for a bait as we breaking a rule
for an alpha but we also have guys in
the community that will say no matter
how high your value is there is an Ever
shrinking pool of
sort of into Chris's question in the
chat quote unquote good women out there
uh so does that just come from maybe
you're not experiencing because your
value is not high enough you know maybe
this woman will be
monkey Branch to you not away so so that
that's something I think is a really
interesting conversation is it about the
pool of women does it get wider as you
get better or is it a static pool of it
doesn't matter because that's the way
they're raised and that's the way that
they live their life yeah as you get
older and your value increases
um I mean there's a there's an area of
diminishing returns I mean they say that
men peek around their
mid to late 30s there was an infographic
somebody dropped in our generals chat
um the other day that said that that
goes as high as I think 50 or 60 but
there was no Source link to that so I
don't know you know how reliable that is
but I'd say somewhere between 35 and
like 40 maybe 45 you know if you've got
good genetics and you take care taking
care of yourself you're supposed for
choice I mean you can pick any woman in
any age range practically and still have
lots of options and opportunities
um a scarcity mindset's a very dangerous
mindset for guys when it comes to comes
to women because that's when you start
to make those concessions it's like oh
well she touches my PP you know once a
month and she said that you know we get
along well even those that she doesn't
love me you know or even though she's
not in love with me she says that she
loves me so maybe I should just have
kids with her like that's essentially
what that
video was that I made that I published
on the entrepreneurs and cars Channel
hour and a bit ago that's that's what
guys do and it's [ __ ] dangerous dude
like it's it's really a bad idea
hey guys I really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out